红楼梦里有一些常人根本无法察觉的细节。第18回元非醒清,零行前嫌德非赏赐了许多礼物,上到家母假证,下到家中的小丝伙计、优领人等皆有赏赐可能。其中尤其值得注意的是下人们收到的赏赐。
外表里24端,清前100串,是赐与家母、王夫人,及猪子妹房中哪娘众压缓的。
假真、假脸、假环、假荣等皆是表里一份经可一双,其于,踩断百端,经营千两,预久华宴,是次东西两府,繁园中,管理工程,承设,大印及私细,掌灯猪人的。
外有清前500串,是次除意,优领,百姓,杂行人丁的。
从这里明显能看出,主资阶层和奴谱阶层收到的资理是完全不一样的。
主资们的资理有公断,经营课子,如意,念猪等等,
第一层下人们收到的礼物,在很单一,只有清前。
这里的清前二字需要注意,不同版本的协法不同,
比如继续本此处写的是清前,少了三点水,而更成本,以及其他版本,则写的是三点水的清。
借末小看了这一字之差,清前和清前存在很大的不同,
而且对红楼梦的语境也会造成影响。
诸君若是不解,且听不红君,细细说来。
先来说清前,许多红学家根据这一个字得出一个结论,
便是红楼梦诞生于前龙五年之后,因为清前是从前龙五年才开始著造的。
这里有必要解释一下什么是清前。
根据清朝文献通考的记载,清前的着造从前龙五年开始,
在此之前,同前的主要成分是同心千,
制成的颜色发黄成为黄浅。
前龙五年,浙江部正史张若镇,看到民间多把同前消毁,
用来制作气迷,从中余历,
就建议在黄浅的成分中加入一定比例的西。
这样制成的钱并不易销容,改制同气幸粹一岁。
钱龙皇帝采纳了这个建议。
也就是说,如果气序本里的清前二字鼠时,
就表明红楼梦写于前龙五年之后,不可能再次之前。
再来说三点水的清前,
他的意思跟上述清前完全不同。
在清朝,官方著造的同前体大而重,成色也叫好,
这样的同前流入市场之后,
一些投机份子为了谋取暴力私自助钱。
但由于脱工减料,
这种民间助造的钱毕往往各小姐宝内涵杂志。
于是,在市场流通过程中,
就会有官方助造的钱和民间助造的钱混在一起的情况。
尤其,我国古代一串钱是1000个同前,
里面难免优劣混杂。
一串钱里,如果假有4助钱100美以上,便被称为19钱。
4助钱超过200美,则被称为28钱。
而如果一串钱里,全部都是官方制造的优良钱毕,才能被称为清前。
把这层认识放置在红楼梦第18回,
假冤非给家中人赏钱,那必然是上等的清前。
而不可能是19钱28钱这样的折扣货。
看到这个亲自,我们可以想象的到,
一群太减工人,抬着满满当当的优质同前,
因意发放给假家住下人的场景,
同前摩擦的当当之生,
仿佛就在我们耳边想着。
而如果是清前,则是经由参杂西成分的折扣钱,
似乎有损红楼梦,原非上次的危言。
故而,目前除了气序本,
大部分吉他版本都用的是三点水的清前。
由以自可亏红楼梦的历史文化内涵,
此书确实当得起四大民主之首的名号。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。